david fincher going back to finch is
something he does
because he's he's a his style of
filmmaking
freaks me out a little bit because it's
so controlled
how do you decide when to move the
camera and when not to move the camera
yeah moving the camera is
it's interesting because and and often
the director and i will discuss you know
in pre-production because some
um some directors or projects
want uh constant movement that maybe
it's like a light float but that is just
always
moving in some capacity
and then
on other projects or other directors
it's like no
only moves
when it's a very specific and important
beat
i've had shows where we didn't move the
camera period and i've had shows where
it's never still and so it really just
it so depends on the project and the
director really because some of it's
just taste and you know i will have my
own
takes on it like if i feel like well
moving in this scene this is such a this
this character is really sad and
if the camera's moving around it's going
to feel too sexy or too exciting and
maybe because it's always moving maybe
now it being static is going to
accentuate that because we're used to it
moving and vice versa so context really
dictates all of it but you do want there
to be a reason not
even if it's a show where everything's
moving
why is it always moving you don't like
it's tricky when
when the reason is
oh it's just cool like it's it's not
that that's wrong there's no right or
wrong but for me again
thoughtfulness is so important to me
like why are things happening and if the
reason is because it's cool like
that's not wrong you know it's just less
exciting it's harder for me to sink my
teeth into that and i think uh
i can get
lazy i get you know if it's just like
well there's no i'm just kind of sliding
the camera around then
i
if i'm not thinking about what i'm doing
uh you know by by day three just like
what what am i doing here
so
so it's it's tricky but you know you
want you want
traveling with like uh something that
david fincher going back to finch is
something he does because he's he's a
his style of filmmaking
freaks me out a little bit because it's
so controlled and i get nervous like
would i even be able to survive a david
fincher shoot i don't know
but his camera tends to lock into actors
if actors are moving the camera's moving
and they're in sync and
that's pretty impressive like when
somebody's getting up and sitting down
the camera but that takes
you know he does 100 takes of stuff like
it
that's hard that's really hard work uh
but that's an approach that makes sense
is if actor moves camera moves factors
still cameras still uh but there is just
you know there is everywhere i mean a
michael bay
thing camera's always alive but that's
because he wants it all to be a
rollercoaster ride and so it's not again
it's not wrong it's just like that's the
that's the aesthetic so i guess it
starts from
a vision
and then hopefully
the camera's movement or lack thereof
at least there's like a string
connecting it to that original vision
and again
intention did you see uncut gems it did
yes that's it yeah uncut gems constantly
moving camera which makes that that
character is constantly moving so yeah
that's a perfect example of something
that like there's a reason for that and
then it's just like go go go because
it's a whirlwind his whole life is a
whirlwind yeah especially in the jewelry
store or out on the street yeah it was
just
constant and and and
i think it worked so well for that film
and it was it really conveyed who he was
as a character what his world was like
yeah that's actually a much better
example because i know michael bay
brings a lot of like people have a lot
of associations but uncut gems is a
great example of
constant camera movement for a reason
and very effective it feels very chaotic
yeah that's great
what tools or equipment should a
beginning cinematographer buy early
because they're going to be using them
all the time that's a good question i
think you know if you can get a fast
lens
i think that is a very useful tool a
lens that can you know opens up to
at least a two let's say well i'd say
two eight is a good minimum but if you
can get something like these rokinons i
mentioned those are a 1.5 or something
uh
i think a fast lands is a very valuable
tool for a couple reasons one you can
shoot in lower light situations so it
just
just helps when you don't have a lot of
gear but also it can teach you
about
depth of field because you can get to
the extreme and you can see what a very
shallow depth of field can do for you
which but also a deep depth of field so
i think that's one of the i would
probably start there
and then beyond that
you know i think it's it's getting
easier now but like a strong light but
those are hard to find cheap but a
strong light source i've noticed
if you can have a strong light source
coming in a window
it gives you such a great baseline to
start from but usually a bigger light is
something that requires a bigger crew
and more money so that's maybe a little
more wishful thinking uh
there's an app called sun seeker and i
think there are a couple other versions
but it can tell you
you know uh
where the sun will be at any time of day
on any day of the year
and if you can really choose those spots
i use it for 100 of the spot unless i'm
in a
set where there are no windows
i want to know where the sun is going to
be and when and then i'm going to use
that to decide what direction we face
and what time of day we want to shoot
there so i think that that's an
indispensable tool as far as i'm
concerned it's kind of expensive but
i think it's it's worth its weight in
gold and actually along those lines
there's an app called artemis
which you can put in any camera and any
set of lenses
and it will
ingest that and then you can take it you
can be like oh i want to see on an alexa
mini 50 millimeter from this position
that's what this will look like oh
actually no we're shooting a different
camera it's going to be a black magic
it's going to be the 6k pocket cam and
we only have a 40 millimeter you plug it
in and same thing
so you can really get a sense of what
each lens is going to show you in a
space so i think those are those are i
mean i use
both of those tools constantly on every
set i've been on for sure
so i think those are huge
um
yeah i think those are those would be
the big ones
anything maybe hold off on it's not as
necessary
well i you know i think we have
um we all have obsessions with
cameras like camera brands and
i think nowadays especially uh
what you can get with a 1 000 camera
blows my mind
and i think
you know there are benefits to cameras
like an alexa or
red or whatever they all have they all
have their advantages but
uh
not feeling like you have to get a
high-end camera to shoot a high-end
image
that is
not the case anymore i would say um one
thing if your camera does not have
internal nd filters neutral density
filters one piece of gear
that i think you do need are neutral
density filters and they have nowadays a
bunch of different brands of um variable
nds and that's something that you can
screw on to the end of a lens and you
can twist it and it will
allow more or less light into your
camera
and there are a number of reasons that
that's beneficial but ideally it allows
you to start being conscious about
shooting at certain f-stops it gives you
control so like shooting um
you know i've shot shows where we're
really opening up and it's a shallower
depth of field a little aimed more
toward beauty and you're shooting at
like a a two or for a lot of it but then
there are other times where i'm like no
we're gonna shoot at a four and it's
deeper depth of field and it feels
different
but you
you don't have that control unless you
have a neutral density filter so that's
something to get
but in terms of yes i think not
obsessing about
quality
of your camera i think that's something
that we all get hung up on
but
the the what you can get now is it it
just boggles my mind it's unbelievable
so i think the
this the floor
has come up so high in terms of the
floor of your image is always going to
be pretty good now in terms of what the
camera can give you at least
so yeah not obsessing about
an expensive camera is probably a big
thing
can you dispel the myth can you really
fix it in post
i hate fixing it in post i am not a
believer in fixing it in post for one
it will often not get fixed in post
because just like in production when you
run out of time and money people run out
of time and money and post and so a lot
of things end up just getting tossed by
the wayside um
and you know it's important to know
when you can
fix something if you're you know you're
on set and you're running out of time
and you're you're the sun is going down
it's like well we're almost out of light
but we can still shoot this but in post
they're gonna have to pull it up it's
not gonna look as good but you know the
range it's like we can get it to a
certain so sometimes out of necessity
but i i hate fixing it in post i
i think it's
when you start hearing that which you
will hear all the time and i will say it
sometimes
but that should never be
where you land if you don't have to and
then when you have to that's the beauty
you can do so much in post these days
but
you shouldn't set out with that as your
initial attitude for sure
you've been asked to do a commencement
speech at a college
what are your final words to
young cinematographers
upcoming generation of filmmakers
cinematographers
yeah you know i never would have guessed
this and i i touched on this earlier but
coming into this industry i never would
have guessed how far
kindness can get you being pleasant to
work with
people are
i've gotten i don't know what other
cinematographers do but a lot of them
apparently it's not good because the
amount of times that different
departments specifically art department
but
and sound and costume that will come up
to me and i'm not i'm not mother teresa
i'm just a normal person the amount of
times that departments come up to me
like andy you're so nice i love working
with you it feels like they've been
abused puppies
that somebody's now giving them a
biscuit like i'm not
so
for me and i same with producers i've
had producers
tell me outright that the reason that
they rehire me is because of the
atmosphere i create on set not the
visual atmosphere just the vibe
and
i
never would have thought that that would
get me work that never even occurred to
me
i'm thankful that that's true it's it's
been good for my career
but
i think
remembering that
this is your life like the way you spend
your day today
is your life and when you're on set
if you suck to be around if you're
unpleasant to be around that is not
gonna serve you
and what an amazing gift that being nice
and happy
can be good for your career like that
that feels too good to be true but
that's exactly what i've found and so i
think embracing film has opened me up as
a person got me to be more confident
less shy because i love it so much
and if it's also teaching me to meditate
and be kinder i never yell i never ever
yell on set i want to yell
but i don't it's teaching me to like
control my emotions don't blow up be
patient
that's i i just
it it brings me so much joy to think
that being better at my career makes me
a better person and being a better
person makes me better at my career so i
would think
that's the best piece of advice is allow
your goodness as a person
to help you be a better craftsman better
to work with everybody wants it i would
assume in every field
you said you went on some road trips um
after 2009 you know you kind of
you know you you didn't really have that
much weighing you down and
what did you see on some of these road
trips
yeah i i'm the big there was some quote
that somebody once told me that akira
kurosawa said and then i've tried to
find it and i've never found it so i
have no idea somebody just said it to me
but
to be a good filmmaker live an
interesting life
and
i spent
a good chunk of my late 20s and early
30s
living a weird life
on the road i was traveling i slept on
couches i slept in cars i slept on the
ground like i was
i was adventuring i was i was living a
life and i was um
looking at the world around me like
literally just looking at the world
uh part of that is looking at light but
part of that seeing
you know
mountains in the snow versus desert in
in the summer versus
you know the seeing an ocean a quiet
lake a busy city
these all have a feeling to them and
emotion and
having that experience you never know
what kind of script will come your way
and what you'll be able to touch on
and then ultimately
people
is to to connect with strangers a
stranger on a bus in the middle of italy
or you know wherever to connect with
different people or just watching
people i think that just gives you
it gives you a richer life which then
gives you a richer palette to pull from
when you're coming up with ideas so i i
really am a big bully now i do wonder
sometimes
had i maybe started my career a little
earlier
would i be further along now
but
what i did in my late 20s early 30s this
kind of vagabond life
was interesting and i would imagine it's
painted by experience which i bring to
my work for sure so i think making sure
i'm a huge film nerd but
living some life outside of movies i
think is a
very valuable thing you know connect
with the world around you as best you
can
you